en tunisie la situation est de plus en
plus inquiétante le pays enregistre
chaque jour un nouveau chiffre record de
décès alors que le système de santé est
à l'agonie c'est que la campagne
vaccinale à peine à décoller le pays a
lancé un appel aux dons notamment en
matière d'appareils de respiration
artificielle
la correspondance à tunis de bassam
chili quatrième vague virulente en
tunisie où tous les voyants sont au
rouge le pays a enregistré samedi 194
nouveaux décès en 24 heures joe cole id
un chiffre jamais atteint depuis le
début de la pandémie 9286 nouvelles
contaminations quotidienne dans un pays
où le système hospitalier sous-financé
est au bord de l'effondrement médecin
société civile et citoyens appellent
désespérément à renforcer les stocks
d'oxygène et art confiné l'ensemble du
pays
de son côté le gouvernement a lancé ce
dimanche un appel à sa diaspora
installées en france pour qu'elles
contribuent par des dons à soutenir le
système de santé à l'agonie côté
vaccination samedi le pays n'a
enregistré qu'un peu moins de deux
millions deux cent mille primo vacciner
afin d'accélérer cette campagne de
vaccination qui peine toujours à
décoller un accord a été conclu entre le
ministère de la santé et le conseil
national de l'ordre des pharmaciens pour
permettre aux pharmaciens privés de
participer à la campagne nationale de
vaccination alors que le confinement
ciblées et les interdictions de circuler
entre les régions sont toujours
maintenues le président de la république
a et sayed a autorisé les forces armées
à vacciner les citoyens à travers tout
le territoire
opération qui a déjà débuté dans le sud
du pays deux avions militaires en
provenance d'égypte ont atterri vendredi
à l'aéroport de tunis avec à leur bord
du matériel médical d'urgence de même
que pour le qatar qui a fait don d'un
hôpital de campagne est de 100 appareils
de respiration artificielle
alors que les émirats arabes unis ont
fait livrer la thune 10 500 mille doses
de vaccin le pays
la patient en rouge a vu sa frontière
avec la libye fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre